[Music]
Denis is heading to TV reality TV how do
you feel about that will we see the kids
on the show I don't know I don't know I
I don't really watch that show Charlie
Sheen on ex-wife Denise Richards joining
the ninth season of The Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills I know it's very
popular and and and and good for her I'm
sure it's gonna be a ball you know Bravo
confirmed the casting decision to ET
earlier this month and here's what
executive producer Andy Cohen told us
about Richards before the news with an
ounce
I love Denise Richards wouldn't it be so
cool to see Denise Richards as a
housewife I think she would be a
sensational housewife in Beverly Hills I
do too yeah have you been talking to
Denise Richards lately I'm always
talking to Denise Richards so great be
great but back to Charlie the 52 year
old actor also teased his own potential
return to TV while chatting with et at
the Project Angel Food Awards in LA on
Saturday do you have a dream role that
would get you back on our TVs it's the
age of reboots and nostalgia
it really is ya know I've been reading a
lot of stuff and many when a lot of
people so it's only a matter of time I'm
just staying patient
[Music]